منافقه عدوانيه وغير مقروءه هكذا وصف
الملياردير ايلون ماسك صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز بعد ازاله شاره التحقق الزرقاء من
الحساب الرئيسي تويتر خطوه نفذها ماسك
بسرعه بعد ان علمان المؤسسه الاخباريه
وعلم انها لن تدفع مقابل خدمه توثيق هذا
الحساب الصحيفه ارجعت هذه الخطوه الى
ضغينه ماسك المستمره منذ سنوات ضد
الصحفيين الامريكيين الذين كتبوا عنه
تقارير انتقاليه كانت نيويورك تايمز واحده
من بضع عشرات من الحسابات التي تمت ازاله
اشارات التوفيق عنها بالفعل الصحيفه رفضت
الدفع لكنها منفتحه للتفاوض وتحذر من
الامتحان
على كل حال للعلم فقط انه سيكلف توثيق
حسابات المستخدمين حوالي 8 دولارات شهريا
لكن الرقم يرتفع كثيرا بالنسبه للشركات
الف دولار شهريا بيت الابيض ايضا قال انه
لا يريد اصلا علامه الزرقاء انت
تدفعي حتى تحصلي على العلامه
راح يتم ازاله العلم الزرقاء باي وانا كل
يوم بفتح بشيك صار لي ثلاثه ايام
بعد ما ينفذ الخطوبه تقرري العقاب لهلا عم
يعاقبني بيت الابيض ما راح يدفع كمان تمام
بس معلش نوضح احنا للمشاهدين مساله
العلامه الزرقاء والتوثيق تفضل انه
العلامه الزرقاء هي مش انه مثلا هذه الجهه
رسميه او جهه حكوميه او شخص مثلا هو مهم
او معين هي انه لتاكيد بان هذا هو الشخص
فعلا نفسه صاحب الحساب فعلا وهذا اللي سبب
الجدل اليوم يصيروا الكل حتى في حدا ينتحل
شخصيتك بسبب علامه التوثيق الزرقاء